[Music]
a range of stories from different
storytellers
is something that we can all learn so
much about the world at large through
you know i wanted to
tell a story that felt very personal to
me very unique to me and kind of
captured the spirit of that like zesty
first generation i literally googled
does anybody give money to women
filmmakers just as a joke
and
this random place came up that was that
was new and they were giving money to
women and i
just cold called them i really love
making movies it's all i don't want to
do this is all i think about so the best
thing for me is like waking up
going set
looking at the sides i am also a doctor
and was in residency the whole time i
was screenwriting and i find it very
grounding to return to the i'm on call
right now i find it very grounding to
return to the hospital and work for
weeks of the year because i'm
like rooted in other people's problems
it was a lot of years i mean i wrote the
movie when i was 24 and we permeated a
year ago and i'm
close to my mid-30s if it's
a couple of years or a decade or you
know it's about
sticking with it